on c'est parti pour les vendanges de la
hausse et relis derniers réglages sur
les machines la petite quarantaine de
domaines à cheval sur l'indre et le cher
est dans les starting blocks
une première pour les 275 hectares de
l'appellation
c'est historique c'est des vendanges les
plus précoces qu'on a jamais connue en
2003 en avant de loger le 30 août
voilà l'année de la canicule donc non
c'est très tôt dans la saison on va
démarrer par les pinots gris à ce qu'on
par lesquels ces pages on commence et
puis ensuite probablement les rouges
avec les pinots noirs et les sauvignons
ensuite la parcelle de pinot gris a
permis d'étalonner la machine
les 32 hectares sont prêts à être en
jambes et un autre parcelle de pinot
gris la grande pièce était déjà mûr
donc c'est vrai comme on a quand même 32
hectares à vendanger
il faut pas trop tarder parce que parce
qu'on en a pour une dizaine de jours 10
12 jours de vendanges
donc après on risque d'être un petit peu
dépassée devant danger n'est pas recèle
un petit peu trop tard 2020 n'est pas
une année très généreuse moins de
chaleur qu'en 2019 et les raisins ont un
peu souffert de la sécheresse
d'après les premières analyses l'acidité
plus élevé que l'année dernière la
qualité sera présente un peu moins la
quantité c'est le travail de toute une
vie avec avec un peu de frustration
parce que le travail des vignes c
et c'est pas forcément un travail facile
et bon cela sur les pinots gris ont
clairement au niveau rendement bas c'est
une petite récolte s'annonce pour les
clés pour les autres cépages comme le
sauvignon ça peut encore attendre la fin
de la semaine prochaine où le début de
la semaine d'après